Josh is with us josh is in Madison
Wisconsin hi Josh how are you I'm good
at what you do better than I deserve
what's up so I've got a question um
regarding a credit card for business
trips and let me kind of explain the
situation here cuz I'm looking for some
advice my wife and I have never been
through FPU but we actually just
recently paid off all of our debt as in
about two and a half weeks ago great
congratulations thank you um I work from
home with a relatively smaller company
okay and they send us on business trips
every once in awhile and we are required
basically to you know pay for some of
those business expenses during the trip
that money is definitely reimbursed the
company that we're going to go see pays
for that what we have to kind of want
that money ahead of time we've closed
out all of our credit cards except for
one for these business trips because we
don't have money you know set aside to
be able to pay for these expenses how
much do the expenses run a month well
I'm not I'm not traveling every single
month but they're I mean every time I go
on a business trip it's it's anywhere
from a thousand to two thousand dollars
covering for the hotels and then you get
even get the money back when you get the
money back within 30 days yeah okay
correct so I mean we're paying we would
be paying that off and obviously when
I'm using the credit card for our own
personal uses the answer the answer is
is that you need to cede that one time
you need to pump from the pump one time
with two thousand dollars in a separate
new checking account that has a debit
card on it and it's used only for one
thing reimbursable business travel and
you use your money on your debit card
and you pray your little company doesn't
go broke and not pay you back mm-hmm
it's a little company you're taking a
big risk
sure you're you're the banker for this
small company that's too small to even
fund their own employees travel that's
pretty scary
at some point they may go belly-up and
you're gonna be left holding a $2,000
ticket in your hand that's the risk
you're taking so well no so the company
that we go and visit they pay you they
pay your company and then your company
pays you right if your company goes
broke they're going to take that money
from that other company and pay other
bills with it and you're gonna be left
out in the cold someday sure I've seen
it happen I've been doing this 30 years
I've seen it happen a lot okay so then
where does that where does that fit in
with that leaves you what's known as up
a creek because you're taking a risk for
this little bitty company that's what
I'm pointing out for you now what I
would tell you do it all with a debit
card if you want to do that that's fine
but at least then you're admitting that
you're taking this risk I would tell you
I'm gonna go back to your little bitty
company and say guys I'm out of debt
I don't like borrowing money I don't
want to borrow money anymore if you want
me to take business trips why don't you
give me the money to take business trips
and then when they pay you back you'll
get your money back mm-hmm it's only
$2,000 right I don't ask my people to
travel here with their money I got a 28
year old young person that's trying to
feed their dogs and their kids and keep
their lights on and I'm gonna send them
out and put airline tickets on their eye
on them no this company here pays for
their airline tickets and we pay for
their rental car and we pay for their
hotel and their food when they travel I
don't ask somebody here to travel and
ask them to pay for it me pay them back
we just pay for it we give them a debit
card we give them the cash when they
leave the place your company should do
that for you and you should push them on
it because you're taking the risk
otherwise but if you don't want to
change the situation you need to fund it
with cash build a debit card do away
with the credit card the bats gonna make
you out that's gonna make your stomach
turn because now you're realizing
there's real risk here because there is
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content
and check out these other great clips
from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]